[Music]
hello I'm at a time warner cable service
center and i'm here with Don and Donna
let me get this straight you're a
technical trainer
yes I am I don't know if you know my
story I worked for a long time in
network television and then now through
a series of crazy events I ended up on
cable just bolts out of blue and I've
been fine I've honestly been fine I'm
happy to be on cable now it's not a
problem
I'm coming to Brian and I'm now as of
today part of the Time Warner Cable
family what do you think about that are
we gonna kill what are we gonna kill it
who we gonna kill what are we gonna chew
it how are we gonna kill it
this is the training yard is that right
yes I'll call yard for training area
this is great somebody slipping here and
your legs will be open and you'll be
meeting the pole on the way you don't
so you're saying my crotch would go into
the pole tell you yes sir
big deal there are don't go up yet huh
no don't go up yeah please okay there
are a lot of concepts here that we kind
of need to understand keep yourself safe
because I don't want you to get to the
top and not be ready for what what you
need to do up there okay so we're gonna
practice they don't first just so you
get the feel of it no matter fact I
wouldn't step back and step 14 yeah now
watch this I'm doing it's just cuz I'm a
maverick I'm gonna jump the rest of the
way you cool with that no it's all the
way down don't form any badass an actual
normal high pole okay that's like three
of these I don't want to go on that if
anything happens to me could you tell my
wife that I'm sorry about my secret
second wife thank you
good god okay yeah keep those knees
straight you don't notice me making a
lot of jokes now do you how do I look
look cool okay so Nick's gonna take me
in the field you've trained me now you
think I'm ready to go that's all the
time we had these would be your tools of
the day what's this that kind of makes
uh perhaps the cable so we can put a
connection are you doing is it okay if
we shoot this on Conan O'Brien I'm
starting a new show on cable that's okay
that's even better
would you like HD HD HD better picture
see HD look at me
and now like this my assistant is from
Armenia soda wolf session so now can you
hear me tell her that Conan O'Brien's
your boss and he's a lovely man okay she
didn't seem convinced try again I just
tell her that the Kardashians are also
Armenian but she didn't seem to
understand but she didn't know about
cher Cher right okay sure yeah she knows
about cher and she also knows about dr.
Kevorkian
14 it's a big lab working I'll tell you
what sorry we're gonna exist take care
this what are we doing now this is the
remote I would like to introduce into
homes right now TBS
right there's fine now let's take me
that way that's it right there
[Music]
[Applause]
you